[Musik]
hallo
hallo hallo anna schön dich zu sehen
und hallo liebe zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer schön euch zu sehen wir
begrüßen euch heute live auf youtube und
auf facebook wir hoffen dass es euch gut
geht und wir sind heute gleich wir haben
gleich einiges programm vorbereitet und
ihr könnt heute auch mit und schreiben
es gibt nämlich einen chat auf youtube
und auf facebook und dort könnt ihr uns
mal einen kommentar schreiben
und vielleicht lesen wir dann euren
kommentar hier vor oder beantworten auch
eure fragen janosch was ist das thema
unseres heutigen live streams
das weiß ich nicht das thema ist manuell
geht spazieren und richtig berichtet uns
von dem was er sieht wir sind heute
wieder live in berlin wir setzen unser
populäres straßen format fort und wir
schalten jetzt mal ganz direkt zu
unserem rasenden reporter manuel
saalmann manuel wo bist du gerade hallo
leute ich stehe auf der marshall brücke
in berlin hinter mir seht ihr die spree
und den reichstag und den
sonnenuntergang und heute mit dabei ist
auch lorenz ich hab die hände frei zum
ersten mal denn lorenz unterstützt uns
an der kamera und ich bin total
aufgeregt
wahnsinn mangel du bist jetzt gerade
live in berlin kann man dich dort
treffen klar also wenn man glück hat
oder pech je nach sichtweise dann könnt
ihr mich jetzt die nächsten 30 bis 40
minuten hier in dieser gegend treffen ja
okay also wenn ihr in der nähe war wohnt
fahrt jetzt schnell zum brandenburger
tor dort werden sie dir manuel sehen
manuel was wirst du uns heute zeigen wir
machen uns jetzt auf den weg also hier
habt ihr schon mal den bundestag bzw den
reichstag so heißt er das gebäude von
hinten gesehen und wir gehen jetzt mal
außen herum schauen uns das berühmte
brandenburger tor an und ein paar andere
orte hier des regierungsviertels als
erstes würde ich euch vielleicht noch
mal kurz das ard-hauptstadtstudio
so zeigen dort sieht man oft abends in
der tagesschau wenn die polit
journalisten die die über die berliner
politik berichten die stehen dann da
oben im fenster und machen ihren bericht
wahnsinn während ihr los geht möchte ich
mal vorlesen für unsere zuschauer heute
herkommen sie kommen aus brasilien aus
den vereinigten arabischen emiraten aus
marokko aus ägypten aus mexiko aus
leipzig aus berlin
ich liebe den aus algerien aus brasilien
aus bayern aus karlsruhe schreibt uns
gerne wo ihr herkommt wir freuen uns
dass ihr live zuguckt indien peking
frankreich viele texas schweiz mailand
die ganze welt guckt zu manuel wie
machen michelin nervös karin
[Gelächter]
libanon serbien
jordanien
es geht weiter türkei england
manuell du läufst jetzt in welche
richtung wir laufen jetzt richtung also
erstmal richtungen hotel adlon das ist
ein sehr bekanntes hotel das heißt doch
so oder ist das doch genau das ist ein
hotel direkt am brandenburger tor da
haben schon viele sehr berühmte und
wichtige menschen übernachtet und auf
dem weg dahin kommen jetzt gleich an der
französischen botschaft vorbei die
britische botschaft sehe ich auch schon
von hier während wir hier an der roten
ampel warten und dann geht es auch schon
weiter zum brandenburger tor manuel du
bist heute in diplomatischer mission
unterwegs im regierungsviertel in berlin
du hast auch das gefährliche tier kommt
der bus 100 mit dem kann man auch eine
schöne
stadtrundfahrt machen für den günstigen
preis von drei euro sieht man viele
tolle orte in berlin das ist schön
manuel du hast gerade schon einen
staatsbesuch gesehen das heißt du hast
eine viele schwarze autos mit polizei
gesehen eine so genannte wagenkolonne
was was hast du da gesehen ist es uns ja
das war kurz bevor wir hier live
gegangen sind kamen hier so eine ganze
kolonne von autos mit polizei
motorrädern vorbei und wenn ich das
richtig gesehen habe aus der ferne war
eine österreichische flagge an der
limousine also das war eventuell einen
staatsbesuch aus österreich so mahne ich
habe das schon recherchiert
und zwar ist das tatsächlich die
ministerpräsidentin von
lettland gewesen
knapp vorbei lettland hat auch eine
ähnliche fahne also rot weiß und ich bin
jetzt hier gerade in angela merkels
privaten terminkalender der ist nämlich
live öffentlich unter bundeskanzlerin de
und dort kann ich sehen was angela
merkel heute geplant hat wenn du gehst
du gleich noch zu angela merkel geste da
vorbei das würde ich doch sagen oder wir
schauen mal was sie so macht in ihren
letzten tagen endlich angela merkel ist
ja noch dort im amt bald also offiziell
ist sie ist sie nicht mehr
bundeskanzlerin sie ist schon man nennt
das sie hat schon ihre erlass
entlassungsurkunde bekommen aber sie ist
jetzt noch geschäftsführend im amt das
heißt sie muss solange die geschäfte
führen bis der bundestag einen
bundeskanzler gewählt hat und das
passiert gleich erst und komma karin
schreibt uns heute ist auch der
staatsbesuch von dänemarks unsere
königin und der kronprinz sind bei euch
zu besuch vielleicht war es auch die
dänische flagge die so gesehen hast seht
ihr auch so ähnlich aus mein gott wir
brauchen mehr liquidität bei den flaggen
würdig sein die dänische flagge ist ja
rot mit einem weißen kreuz drin war das
war guck mal was ich glaube die flagge
die hier zwischen der europäischen und
der deutschen hängt wir sind
wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen zu weit
weg davon vielleicht war es ja die okay
wir machen jetzt flaggen rate schleif
mit manuel janisch kennst du dich mit
flaggen aus nicht besonderes
es wird spannend leute hier ist nämlich
alles abgesperrt von der polizei guck
mal vielleicht hätten wir mal
recherchieren sollen was hier heute so
los ist ja
wir sind warte mal ganz kurz ich spreche
mal ganz kurz mit dem polizist mit
da kannst du mal kurz uns aus wänden gut
dann wird man gleich zurück sein ist
gibt es sei denn er wird festgenommen
manu ist jetzt bei der polizei wir
machen hier live weiter es gibt
tatsächlich heute mehrere staatsbesuche
der lettische die lettische mindest der
lettische ministerpräsident ist da der
portugiesische premierminister
und die dänische königin und ihr mann da
ist heute einiges los in berlin janosch
oder ja die stehen offensichtlich
schlange
die stehen schlange um zu sagen igor
schreibt manuel steckt in
schwierigkeiten
es könnte sein aber ich glaube nicht
wisse wie sehen manuel regelt dass da im
hintergrund
mal schauen was passiert ihr könnt ja in
der zwischenzeit uns fragen stellen in
den kommentaren hier an der heute mal an
dieser seite an dieser seite oder hier
unten schreibt uns mal einen kommentar
manuel ist wieder da ich
ja
darüber
da hierdurch ja super vielen dank so die
netten polizisten haben das mal kurz
geklärt für uns also tatsächlich
handelt es sich um den staatsbesuch der
dänischen königsfamilie
deswegen ist hier gerade alles
abgesperrt und eigentlich darf nur die
akkreditierte presse also die
journalisten zu denen ich mich jetzt
noch nicht unbedingt zählen würde
hierdurch aber wir haben jetzt die
offizielle erlaubnis bekommen hier
nochmal so durchzumischen damit wir euch
kurz das brandenburger tor zumindest
zeigen können vorher nicht genau wir
dürfen jetzt aber nicht hier bleiben und
auf die königsfamilie warten denn dafür
sind wir nicht akkreditiert
es ist aber toll dass du das geklärt hat
mit der polizei ja da sind ja auch noch
offensichtlich andere menschen im
sicherheitsbereich die da im bei
starbucks sitzen genau also wir zeigen
jetzt mal ganz kurz was hier los ist
also hier seht ihr jetzt das
brandenburger tor und die menschen die
also auf das königshaus warten
und in der mitte da steht dann wirklich
die akkreditierte presse ja da dürfen
wir nur mal eben nicht hin aber wir
dürfen jetzt hier einmal vorbei laufen
und von königin margrethe das sind die
fans und hier ist immer was los auf
diesem platz oder also ich hab das
gefühl zu jeder tages und nachtzeit kann
man hier hinkommen und und immer
irgendeine überraschung da sind dänemark
fans wie soll er mit denen nicht
sprechen wir freuen uns schreibt uns
doch mal wenn ihr aus dänemark kommt das
ist heute eine spezial episode nur für
euch liebe leute mahne ich finde das
total spannend ich finde du solltest
jetzt dabei bleiben fragt auch da mal
jemanden wann die kommen vielleicht ist
das ja vielleicht passiert das ja jetzt
ja das mache ich gerne wir schauen mal
ob ich jemanden finde vielleicht könnt
ihr kurz ein paar fragen beantworten und
dann melde ich mich gleich wenn ich
jemanden gefunden habe ja machen wir so
machen wir so
gut dann würde ich sagen wir nutzen die
zeit um ein paar fragen zu beantworten
ja nun bist du bereit
und zwar gibt es hier die frage ist es
heute kalt in berlin aber manuell das
kann ich persönlich nicht beantworten
denn ich habe heute das haus noch nicht
verlassen aber ich kann bei wetteronline
sehen ist es sieben grad war heute
draußen und janosch ganz angenehm frisch
aber angenehmen sieben grad ist schon
eher kalt dann hat wie wir geschrieben
wie spät ist es in berlin bei uns ist es
jetzt aktuell 16 uhr
11.4 uhr 11 am nachmittag und wir haben
jetzt gerade die winterzeit wir haben
die uhren umgestellt und im winter ist
es bei uns tatsächlich ab 4 uhr dunkel
das ist ein bisschen traurig oder ja na
ja aber
man muss das immer im verhältnis sehen
wenn es kalt dass ich aber gut angezogen
bin dann ist es trotzdem toll oder wenn
es
sind da draußen ist aber ich in meinem
inneren leuchte dann ist auch die
balance wieder das freut mich ahmad
schreibt was trinkst du janisch ich
trinke einen espresso ein cappuccino
ein cappuccino manuel ist wieder da sehe
ich gerade mal ihr lieben ich stehe
jetzt hier mit thomas hallo thomas hallo
und so was tatsächlich wir sind sehr
unvorbereitet wir wussten gar nicht was
hier heute los ist kannst du uns in
wenigen sätzen erklären warum durch es
stehst und was hier gleich passiert ja
hallo erst mal ich bin zufällig hier ich
wollte nur das bamberger tor sehen und
habe dann von den dänischen kollegen
erfahren dass die dänische königin hier
gleich vorbei kommen soll unternehmen
stehe ich als ok und wann kommt die
familie hier vorbei sollte schon da sein
also ich gehe mal davon aus dass wir
gleich so weit sein
fantastisch ja vielen dank viel spaß
hier noch und alles gute
der jetzt da bleiben weil ich soll hier
bleiben ja ja wir wollen so dass
besucher sehen wir wollen day4 jemanden
der etwas bescheid weiß kunde für
familie von der königlichen familie der
uns ein bisschen hintergrundwissen
erzählen könnte ja kann das ja unsere
zuschauer aus dänemark machen schreibt
uns doch mal ein kommentar wie findet
ihr das denn dass manuel leicht die
dänische königin sieht ist das etwas was
euch persönlich berührt kenny hat uns
gefragt warum verwendet ihr immer noch
sommer und winterzeit ich verstehe es
nicht
langsam ich verstehe das auch nicht aber
ich freue mich immer weil ich dann immer
ein bisschen überrascht
ich habe ein paar uhren die automatisch
sich von selbst verstellen und einige
nicht und die bleiben auch uns erstellt
also ist tatsächlich so dass das schon
längst geändert werden sollte die
meisten leute in europa möchten das
ändern aber es ist noch nicht geändert
worden
manuel sonne mal ein paar historische
bilder zeigen vom brandenburger tor das
ist ja ein sehr historischer platz den
früher stand dort auch die berliner
mauer und dieser bezirk oder dieser ort
wurde jetzt stehst der war viele viele
jahre überhaupt nicht zugänglich das ist
eine sehr gute idee das ist ja der
pariser platz hier und der sieht
tatsächlich ganz anders aus als er
früher aussah und ich bin gespannt
welche bilder du für uns vorbereitet
hast da hat uns auch jemand gefragt ist
manuel am pariser platz ich möchte auf
google maps folgen also wenn ihr auf
google maps folgen möchtet mangelware an
der marshall bridge oder marshall brücke
und ist jetzt am pariser platz und er
plant danach zum reichstag zu gehen also
das alles es geht los es geht los
kommt die königsfamilie
na bravo damit hätte ich gerechnet dass
wir das hier heute man ist da auch ein
deutscher ein deutsches staatsoberhaupt
dabei oder laufen die da alleine schau
mal ich sehe viele securitys da in der
mitte da ist auch die königin margrethe
und wehrleute neben ihr
tja
da mehr kenne ich mich zu wenig aus ich
habe zwar mal ein bisschen über die
königshäuser gelernt als ich für eine
quizshow lernen musste aber mehr weiß
ich auch nicht so königin margrethe von
dänemark also eigentlich sind ja jetzt
unsere dänischen fans gefragt
unser nächster könig ist zu besuch da es
ist lustig für mich die dänische fahne
bei euch zu sehen die dänische königin
und ihr sohn sind in dänemark sehr
beliebt schreibt karin
ja da ist sie schon wieder vorbei wir
sehen jetzt hier gar nicht so viel denn
es ist ein bisschen verpixelt ja es ist
aber ehrlich gesagt auch gar nicht so
viel passiert also sind jetzt hier
vorbei gelaufen ein paar vereinzelte
menschen haben geklatscht aber ja nicht
auch so viele ich sehe da hinten ein
paar fahnen
im wind und das war's also königin
margrethes 81 und ihr sohn kommt grund
prinz frederik der nächste könig ist 53
das sind jetzt die zeit facts die ich
herausgefunden habe sind das
interessante fakten manuel sehr sehr
interessant und ja was für ein
verrücktes leben oder also total ich
hoffe dass du gleich noch angela merkel
trifft wollen wir kurz uns die zeit
nehmen einen blick in die geschichte zu
wagen
francisco bitten uns das bild mauer
nummer eins zu zeigen dort sieht man
nämlich diesen bereich jetzt
1961 und zwar steht manuel jetzt links
vom brandenburger tor
und man sieht dort dieses ganze areal
diese diese diesen ort wo man jetzt ist
jetzt gibt es da ganz viele gebäude und
damals also vor dem fall der mauer vor
1989 war das alles ein sperrbezirk das
heißt dass tatsächlich dort die mauer
stand man durfte auch nicht in die nähe
der mauer gehen und es gab dort
eigentlich auch fast gar keine gebäude
man sieht dort das brandenburger tor
ganz alleine stehen und links und rechts
gibt es keine gebäude und mittlerweile
gibt es dort jetzt zum beispiel die
französische botschaft links es gibt die
amerikanische botschaft dahinter das
holocaust mahnmal das sind alles sachen
die früher nicht daran und man sieht
rechts um das tor herum die mauer du
kannst mal das zweite bild zeigen aber
warte ich hätte noch eine beschwerde zu
diesem bild ja und zwar ich bin
ich weiß nicht mehr genau aber irgendwo
ende 80er jahre bin ich nach berlin
geflogen
und zwar absichtlich geflogen weil ich
immer noch angst hatte
durch die ddr zu fahren weil ich ja ein
flüchtling war und da
stand ich vor der mauer
direkt gegenüber dem
brandenburger tor es gab solche
klettergerüste für touris h die dürften
darauf klettern und so hatten sie eine
sehr guten ausblick
und du kannst du mal das bild zeigen von
1983 da sieht man nämlich den blick den
janus gerade beschreibt
die mauer aus sicht von west berlin in
den 80er jahren also man sieht dort die
mauer dahinter das brandenburger tor
dieses gerüst wovon des schreib sieht
man nicht aber man sieht dort ein schild
achtung sie verlassen jetzt
westberlin also das war nur eine warnung
denn man konnte dort gar nicht über die
mauer oder durch die mauer aber genau zu
diesem ort gehst du jetzt hin manuel und
man sieht dort ja im boden noch heute
wurde die mauer stand
genau ist das nicht ach das ist doch
direkt hier vor uns das ist jetzt agenda
zufall dass hier gerade rot ist hier
diese steine im boden die jetzt hier
direkt vor uns sind das ist die linie wo
früher die mauer verlief die es in ganz
berlin also so markiert da kann man
wirklich einmal komplett auch eine
fahrradtour machen wenn man möchte dann
sieht man einmal wo die mauer entlang
lief und man sieht wirklich das war also
direkt hinter dem brandenburger tor
beziehungsweise vor dem brandenburger
tor ja genau das ist genau fast genau
dieser blick den wir gerade im foto
gesehen haben heute kann man einfach
durchgehen früher gab es dort die mauer
und dort standest du in den 80er jahren
ja naja aber auch diesem gerüst weil ich
sage ich habe auch die soldaten die da
unten stehen gesehen und ja es war
malerisch es war total
fremd für mich deshalb habe ich noch
wenige
assoziationen gehabt ich wusste im
grunde nicht was ich david wie sehe ich
wusste nur dort hinter dieser mara ist
ost berlin und ostdeutschland und zu der
zeit noch 1 1 für mich sehr
dunkler bedrohlicher regime und
hunde eine geschichte die sich kaum hat
zustand lassen können während manuel
weitergeht können wir noch mal einen
blick werfen auf ein bild von
1984 und in diesem bild sieht man
nämlich das brandenburger tor von der
anderen seite das ist die ostseite auch
in den 80er jahren und da sieht man dass
man auch nicht direkt bis zum tor gehen
kann ganz hinten sieht man die mauer
ganz klein und vorne gibt es eine
besucher sperre also man kann dort sich
das brandenburger tor von der weite
angucken sieht ganz ganz nett aus aber
es ist tatsächlich ein abgesperrter
bereich gewesen
nanu wo gehst du denn jetzt hin wir
gehen jetzt hier gerade ja das ist schon
der tierpark glaube ich also es gibt ja
hier einen sehr der tiergarten natürlich
einen sehr großen park der aber
tiergarten heißt und das ist hier so
sage ich mal die die äußerste ecke von
diesem doch sehr großen park und
vor uns sehen wir schon das kanzleramt
das sehen wir später noch mal
hoffentlich aus der nähe wenn lorenz und
ich uns jetzt beeilen und rechts von uns
ist der reichstag also da versuche ich
jetzt mal noch ein bisschen näher ran zu
kommen damit wir uns hier noch mal von
vorne anschauen können
der tiergarten ist tatsächlich einer der
größten stadtparks die es gibt in europa
glaube ich oder vielleicht sogar der
welt ist ein riesiger park in der mitte
berlins weißt du warum der tiergarten
heißt rheinland janisch erzählt uns
einer der
in berlin hat sich
wollte hatte keine lust zum jagen
irgendwelche längere strecken zu fahren
also hat es sich einen riesigen park
bauen lassen hat dort die am wilden
tiere verfrachtet und hat sie dort quasi
abgeknallt dann ist einfach als freiheit
mein gott
ich hoffe ich habe nichts irgendetwas
verdreht aber
das hast du sehr positiv geschrieben
werden ist tatsächlich ein ein
jagdrevier gewesen man konnte dort jagen
ob das künstlich angelegt wurde oder
tatsächlich damals schon also gar nicht
erst verbaut wurde das weiß ich jetzt
nicht weil
ja damals war ja berlin auch noch nicht
so dicht bebaut wie heute und es gab
einfach noch verschiedene gebiete und
eigentlich städte die jetzt
zusammengewachsen sind
denn da zwischen das von kasten da ja
dieser diese kästen diese container dass
die stehen tatsächlich immer hier obwohl
sie sehr provisorisch aussehen das ist
der eingang für besucher in den
reichstag haben wir auch schon oft
empfohlen auch im podcast schon mal als
empfehlungen der woche glaube ich wenn
man nach berlin kommt sollte man
unbedingt dieses gebäude besuchen denn
es ist sehr interessant und diese kuppel
da oben drauf die kann man eben auch
besteigen man hat eine schöne aussicht
auf berlin und was man aber dann
unbedingt vorher machen muss ist im
internet ein termin zu machen das ganze
ist kostenlos und dann läuft man hier
durch diese container wird gecheckt muss
einmal durch die sicherheitskontrolle
und dann darf man also hier in den
eingang
ja ich lese gerade mal fragen von
unseren zuschauern da fragte vorkam ole
macht ihr jetzt jeden monat einen live
stream
gute frage hier der woche
einmal im monat so ungefähr ist unser
unser ziel immer wenn königs besuch ist
richtig und darin schreibt es ist viel
besser jetzt seitdem manuel ein bisschen
hilfe beim livestream hat lorenz du
kannst du zwar hören aber du wirst
gelobt von unseren zuschauern die kamera
arbeit ist toll besser als wenn ich als
ich selbst gefilmt habe okay dann gibt
es noch eine frage von endo er möchte
gerne wissen welche fußballmannschaft
wir unterstützen da muss ich leider
sagen wir sind alle drei keine
fußballfans da haben wir leider keine
besondere referenz
das ist mir dein du was früher bei
bayern münchen für ich nein kari ich
nicht darüber reden
aurélie möchte wissen geht manuel zur
siegessäule
das also da müssten wir dann gleich ein
bisschen joggen
die siegessäule ist dort drüben das
schaffen wir aber nicht mehr weil wir
wollen euch natürlich noch zeigen wo
angela merkel im moment noch arbeitet
das heißt wir haben uns jetzt auf den
weg gemacht normalerweise kann man hier
über die grüne wiese zwischen reichstag
und bundeskanzleramt einfach drüber
laufen aber hier scheint schon wieder
irgendein event zu sein also da steht
eine bühne und hier ist alles abgesperrt
deswegen laufen wir jetzt außen rum aber
zur siegessäule das schaffen wir nicht
mehr hier ist mal eine sprachliche frage
von andrea was ist der unterschied
zwischen tor und tür
ein tor ist groß und eine tür ist klein
ja das ist richtig also ein tor ist ja
was großes ein gebäude fast oder ein
großer eingang eigentlich zu einem
gebäude und die tür ist ein kleines ding
michael möchte wissen ist das ist
reichstag das gebäude und bundestag die
gruppe von politiker innen oder was ist
der unterschied zwischen reichstag und
bundestag sehr gute frage
er hat eigentlich michael selber schon
beantwortet reichstag ist das gebäude so
nennt man heute noch das gebäude und der
bundestag ist im prinzip das ja das
regierungsorgan dass in dem reichstag
ist also man könnte sagen die gruppe von
politikerinnen die im bundestag sitzen
sie sind zusammen der bundestag ja aber
ich würde sagen die deutschen
verwechseln das auch auf die sagen ich
gehe zum bundestag oder ich gehe zum
reichstag die benutzten das auf die hre
hatte
manuel möchte unterheben es sah so aus
als würden sie was auf der karte suchen
sendet von dir manuel sehr umsichtig
freue mich immer wenn ich die reaktion
wie sagt man also weg bei der beim weg
helfen kann aber manchmal vertue ich
mich auch und dann
hast du doppelt spaß hier ist eine frei
von macht aber er fragt ist die
brandenburger tor in ost berlin gebaut
dazu kann ich sagen das brandenburger
tor ist schon sehr viel früher gebaut
worden als es ost und west berlin gab
nämlich
1789 schulen also das ist mehr als 100
jahre vorher mehr als 200 jahre vorher
also das ist schon sehr viel älter das
brandenburger tor als die teilung
manuel ja wo läufst du jetzt gerade hin
erzählt uns ein bisschen was ja also wir
sehen jetzt die wiese von der ich gerade
sprach
und sehen hier den bundestag daneben ich
wenn ich mich nicht irre ist dass das
paul löbe haus es ist auf jeden fall
eins der gebäude in denen die
abgeordneten also diejenigen politiker
die dann im bundestag sitzen die haben
in diesem gebäude ihr büro ihre
mitarbeiter haben dort ihr büro und vor
und sieht man jetzt schon das
bundeskanzleramt und all diese gebäude
es gibt noch ein paar mehr gebäude die
quasi zu der
bundesregierung oder zu diesem
regierungsviertel gehören die sind alle
unterirdisch verbunden das weiß ich weil
ich auch mal recht ein praktikum bei
einem bundestagsabgeordneten gemacht
habe und dann durfte ich auch durch
diese tunnel laufen und tatsächlich ist
hier oben nämlich meistens nicht viel
los man sieht ja auch jetzt nicht viele
leute hier und hier ist aber tatsächlich
meistens reger betrieb unter der erde da
laufen die mitarbeiter und die politiker
dann bundestag zu gebäude einst zu
gebäude 2 und so weiter das ist sicher
weiter wissen manuel das wussten wir
haben schon ich auch nicht warst du da
mal drin im tunnel ja ja ich bin dadurch
gelaufen stand auch mal mit frank walter
steinmeier im aufzug tatsächlich
unserem bundespräsidenten damals war ja
noch nicht bundespräsident aber genau
ich habe hier viel erlebt gibt es dort
auch geschäfte und und die saunas und
mini das ist überhaupt nicht glamourös
das sind so ganz kahle tunnel da läuft
man nur schnell durch also ist nichts
nicht besonders das sowieso ein
flughafen und erich du beantwortet jetzt
perfekt ich frage von gh wo wir und der
kanzler also im moment haben wir ja noch
eine kanzlerin und die wohnt tatsächlich
nicht dort aber sie arbeitet dort da
gibt es aber eine easy german episode wo
wir zu angela merkels wohnung gegangen
sind ja nur schwäche episode war das
kannst du dich erinnern er fragte ich
meinen dass google ich mal eben
nicht wir standen schon einmal an an
ihrer wohnung auch damals hatte ich ein
nettes gespräch mit einem polizisten der
uns erlaubt hat dort zu drehen wir
durften dann nur nicht den polizisten
film also das lief alles sehr fair und
also frau dr merkel wohnt ja nicht weit
von hier aber in einer wohnung
und jetzt stehe ich aber tatsächlich vor
ihrem büro sozusagen bzw dem gebäude in
dem ihr büro sich befindet und daneben
auch demnächst der zukünftige
bundeskanzler es wird ja wahrscheinlich
ein mann sein sitzen wird und arbeiten
wird und dann eben auch
gäste empfangen wird und so weiter
dieses gebäude meinte lorenz er soll die
kamera gerade halten nur rennst du
sollst weil die kann man noch etwas
begradigen der ausrichten und dieses
gebäude das nennt man auch die
waschmaschine
das sieht man aber eher wenn man von der
seite drauf guckt das hätten wir gerade
oder da konnte man das vielleicht schon
mal so sehen dass an der seite da so
runde
so eine runde fläche ist und deswegen
nennt man das auch die waschmaschine
weil es ein bisschen aussieht wie die
waschmaschine also nicht so schön wie
andere
paläste regierungspalast
hs ist dass es fragen sehr viele leute
wie das wetter ist wir haben eben schon
gesagt dass es sieben grad ist aber
vielleicht möchten die menschen deine
emotionen höheren manuel wie ist das
wetter wie fühlt es sich an
also ehrlich gesagt komm lorenz wir
gehen in richtung bahnhof dann können
wir gleich die über nach hause nehmen
ehrlich gesagt ist es ich bin dick
angezogen es ist gar nicht so kalt es
ist irgendwie sieben grad lorenz hat
auch keine handschuhe an also ich habe
mich sehr gut vorbereitet weil ich
dachte oh dass wird kalt aber es ist
eigentlich ein sehr schöner tag heute
noch für berliner verhältnisse
das ist schön da
fragen wir mal gucken wir mal was es
hier noch für fragen gibt und jammern
ich freue mich total dass du so viel
action heute erlebt hast geh doch mal
kurz zum eingang vom bundeskanzleramt
und schau mal ob da jemand raus kommt
das ist rechts daneben da ist der
offizielle ein gehör das wusste ich zum
beispiel nicht okay also das jetzt hier
ist der 1 da bin ich ja rein gegangen
man sieht einfach dieses das wäre zum
beispiel ein tor ein sehr modernes tor
da wird jetzt gerade das gitter
hochgefahren
da kann man da fahren die staatsgäste
rein und raus kümmert da kommt jetzt
gleich ein auto raus und da vorne in
diesem kleinen gebäude da sitzt die
polizei und macht security checks also
wenn du da rein gehst musst du wie am
flughafen
deine sachen abgeben und dich scannen
lassen und dann auch einiges los ein
weiteres highlight manuel die schweizer
botschaft ist in sichtweite da gibt es
auch eine easy german episode wir
verlinken weiter diese videos später in
denen in der infobox denn da habe ich
aber eine interview gemacht mit der
damaligen schweizerischen botschafterin
das war auch sehr schön ja es war
übrigens episode 344 als du mit janisch
durch berlin gefahren willst uns doch
mal den eingang vom bundeskanzler ist
auch so schild daneben naja ok hier wir
wollen nochmal hier sieht man also
bundeskanzler abends frau auf grau das
ist der spieler der eingang her das ist
der eingang hier steht es doch offiziell
ein silberner adler auf dem jahr ein der
bundesadler und genau also hier sieht
man dass so ein bisschen warum das
waschmaschine heißt also da oben dieser
bogen
das ist quasi
der grund warum es so heißt
manuel ich finde du hast eine richtig
gute strecke heute geschafft
jetzt sollen sie uns noch den bahnhof
zeigen genau wollte ich gerade noch
machen also hier das ist der berliner
hauptbahnhof noch relativ neue waren
wurde der erbaut berlin hatte ja lange
keinen hauptbahnhof richtig und es gab
ja also das haben wir vielleicht eben
nicht so richtig gesagt ist dadurch dass
berlin geteilt war gab es kein richtiges
zentrum es gab eigentlich mehrere
stadtzentren und es gab auch mehrere
bahnhöfe mehrere flughäfen und alsdann
deutschland wiedervereinigt wurde und
berlin wieder vereinigt wurde hat man
diesen ganzen bereich der früher wo
vorher nichts war den hat man ausgebaut
zum regierungsbezirk und man hat dort
einen hauptbahnhof hingebaut ja in den
neunzigern und 2000er jahren
und ich erinnere mich dass
kurz nachdem er dann endlich fertig war
das war ja auch ein sehr teures projekt
dieser gläserne bahnhof ganz tolles ganz
tolle architektur
da ist dann kurz danach hat es ganz doll
geschneit in berlin und das lag ganz
hoch schnee und vorne über dem eingang
vom bahnhof das sehen wir jetzt gleich
wenn dieser baum hier weg ist da ist so
ein vordach also so ein dach was über
den eingang drüber geht und das ist am
anfang einmal eingekracht ich weiß nicht
ob ihr euch da noch daran erinnern könnt
ja manuel wir beantworten noch zwei
fragen würde ich sang und zwar einmal
ist dass die von michael ist olaf scholz
schon zum kanzler gewählt worden
yakari das kannst du gut beantworten da
hast du letztens im pop schon darüber
gesprochen er ist noch nicht gewählt
worden denn die
koalitionsverhandlungen laufen noch das
heißt die regierung muss sich erst
formieren und dann wählen sie den
kanzler dann müsst ihr jemand der
schreibt janisch du solltest auch mal
reden aber
ich genieße heute meine stellung als
beobachter
haben du kannst vielleicht noch einmal
zusammenfassen wie hat manuel das bisher
gemacht seinen job als rasender reporter
in berlin ja ganz toll ich wäre sowieso
dafür dass wir das hier der woche machen
jeden mittwoch einfach und wir nennen
das mittwochs gehe durch spenden
mitarbeit in gängen
[Gelächter]
hänge durch berlin ich finds perfekt ist
ist ein wunderschöner hintergrund jetzt
guck mal da ist der himmel so richtig
lila und das ist doch ein schönes
abschlussbild manuel im sonnenuntergang
wir haben dich beobachtet du hast ein
staatsbesuch gesehen du warst am
hauptstadtstudio von der ard was am
brandenburger tor du warst an beim
amtssitz von angela merkel was will man
mehr manuell was will man mehr das
einzige was ich mir noch wünsche ist
dass ihr liebe zuschauerinnen und sich
aber ein mitglied werdet von easy german
damit wir janus traum erfüllen können
und jede woche so was verrücktes hier
machen können
und ansonsten hat es mir heute auch sehr
viel spaß gemacht tatsächlich das war
die perfekte zusammenfassung manuel das
ist tatsächlich etwas wo wir euch
einladen ihr könnt ein mitglied werden
von easy german katrin dot com / german
ist die website das ist ein
mitgliederservice oder einzahlung
service den wir benutzen und darüber
könnt ihr ein mitglied werden für ein
monat für zwei monate vielleicht auch
für drei jahre es gibt leute die sind
schon sehr lange dabei und als mitglied
könnt ihr uns unterstützen einmal also
wir finanzieren unser projekt durch
diese mitgliedschaften denn wie ihr
wisst sind ja unsere videos und unsere
podcast episoden umsonst für alle
zugänglich aber ihr bekommt auch etwas
als mitglied und zwar manuel und zwar
bekommt ihr zu unseren videos
interaktive übungen so lückentexte und
vokabel listen das heißt ihr könnt dann
wirklich mit dem video auch etwas lernen
und dann gibt es noch verschiedene
andere angebote da seht ihr so
verschiedene levels zu unserem podcast
und auch eine community membership wo
ihr täglich mit uns ketten könnt also
schaut euch das einfach mal an
es war toll mit euch ja nächste mal
schicken wir dich wieder auf die straße
wo darf ich mir auch den die strecke
aussuchen wann hast du schon ich würde
gerne durch den flohmarkt laufen das ist
eine tolle idee
das ist eine sehr schöne idee nächstes
mal sind wir wahrscheinlich erst mal auf
dem weihnachtsmarkt das war eine idee
die wir hatten stimmt und da werden wir
uns dann melden ja liebe leute es war
schön mit euch danke dass ihr alle zu
gesehen habt danke an lorenz hinter der
kamera danke an francisco hinter den
kulissen hier als regie regisseur kann
man sagen und danke auch an eric der
sich um die community gekümmert hat was
schön mit euch allen und ich freue mich
schon auf den nächsten live stream und
dann vielleicht mit
dem amerikanischen präsidenten manuel
wer weiß zb